Hi everyone, my name is Sarah Kane. I'm a PhD student in astronomy at the
University of Cambridge and I am one of the co-instructors for this non-visual
data science tutorial series alongside Patrick Smith who is a blind programmer
and programming instructor and consultant with the Iota School. This is
the fourth of the five tutorial series.  Today we'll begin talking about data
sonification and the next tutorial, next week, will also cover the same topic.
Again these tutorials take place Tuesdays from 6 to 8 p.m. UK time, that's my time
zone, 1 to 3 p.m. Eastern Time in the US or whatever that corresponds to in your
respective time zone. These tutorials are being very generously supported by Pandas
and Numfocus which makes them free and available to all of you and all of the
recording you're watching right now and all of the written curricula are online
and available to you.  I really encourage you to check out the curriculum, it's got
all of the code we'll go over as well as some more details and you know written
instructions for everything we're doing today if you want to revisit it in
written form and of course Patrick and I are always happy to answer your
questions over email. We also have office hours on Thursdays from 6 to 8 p.m. UK
time, 1 to 3 p.m. Eastern Time in the US and so on and so forth over the same
zoom link that this live tutorial occurs. Now those of you who are watching this
right now might be able to tell that this is not a live zoom course happening.
We're currently, well I, this is not the Royal We, but I am currently re-recording
this tutorial. We had some unfortunate sound difficulties during the live zoom
so we wanted to make sure there was a nice clean version with no sound
difficulties available to everyone for posterity so to speak. So I'm excited to
go over this curriculum again with all of you and again if you have questions
please feel free to reach out.  Now without further ado, especially because
there's no one else here with me, I think we're just going to jump right into
things. So as you have before I encourage you now to open up Anaconda prompt. I'm
already on the screen, I'm going to turn on my NVDA speech again, didn't want it
talking over me during the intro.  Speech mode beeps, speech mode talk. Excellent
and hopefully you can hear that okay. Okay so open up Anaconda prompt as we
have in the previous three tutorials.  If you are not already there like I am you
can do that by hitting the Windows key and typing in Anaconda prompt to open it
up. Again this is Anaconda prompt not Anaconda navigator and what I want you
to do right now is not to start IPython. Again please do not start IPython yet
which is what we do usually after opening Anaconda prompt because
that's the sort of interactive workspace we have to write code and test it.  But
what we're actually about to do right now is to do something called installing
a package. Now we've used packages in the previous tutorials. We've used pandas and
NumPy.  These are like libraries of code that other people have written that we
can now make use of and those packages because they're really popular and
widely used are available with the Anaconda installation that you already
have. But some less common packages like Astronify which is the sonification
package that we're going to use today is not already pre-installed with Anaconda.
So we're gonna have to install it ourselves.  No worries it's a pretty
simple. It's as simple as one line of code actually. But before we get into that I
want to just go over a few caveats.  First of all unfortunately to our knowledge we
really only expect the Astronify installation to work properly on Windows
computers and also maybe on older MacBooks. If you have a MacBook with one
of the newer Mac chips so not an Intel chip but a Mac chip so that's the M1, M2,
M3 Mac we have had no luck getting Astronify to work on those new Macs.
Likewise if you are a Linux person using Linux unfortunately we also have not had
luck getting Astronify to work on Linux.  This alongside our desire to use
NVDA as the screen reader we're teaching with is kind of one of the
motivations for us encouraging all of you to use Windows for this tutorial
series. Also if you have other packages already installed so say you already
program a bunch and have other things installed on your Anaconda it is
possible that this might not work. It's really hard to predict how different
package dependencies might not get along with each other, might not work out
properly.  So if you have some sort of error message because you have other
packages already installed please do let Patrick and I know either in office
hours or over email and we will try to help you out. But for the vast majority
of you who have installed Anaconda nice and fresh for this course this should be
quite simple. We hope anyway.  Cross your fingers. So installing Astronify and
I've uninstalled it actually so that I can install it with you now is as simple
as one line that we're going to type again not in IPython just in the Anaconda
prompt. We are going to type PIP.  PIP is our package manager here. It's the
one managing all these libraries of code. PIP is the thing that's going to install
this package for us.  There's another package manager out there called Conda.
Some things are available via Conda others via PIP. We won't get into that.
This one we're going to use PIP and if you're curious check out the curriculum
online where I talk about it a little bit more. So it's PIP P-I-P space space
install "I-N-S-T-A-L-L" PIP space install space Astronify "space A-S-T-R-O-N
R-O-N-I-F-Y" PIP install Astronify A-S-T-R-O-N-I-F-Y and hit enter.
"Collecting Astronify. Using cached Astronify 0.1 pi 3 none any dot WHL.
Requirement already satisfied. Astropy in C. Users." Alright so I'm going to stop
that now because there's a lot of text happening there. So I don't want you to
hear all of it but I wanted some of it to play because I don't want you to feel
like alarmed when NVDA starts reading out just this absolute barrage of text.
It should mostly be along the lines of like requirement already satisfied you
know installing XYZ.  If you start getting some angry sounding messages
like you know couldn't do this or whatnot that's a good time to start
maybe doing some googling or contacting Patrick and I but hopefully it'll all
be nice things that are like requirement already satisfied and it should end with
successfully installed Astronify and that should be all you need to do.
Occasionally I think I've seen some people get a message where it says
proceed question mark yes why slash no and you have to hit type Y for yes and
then hit enter. I don't think most of you should get that but if you do not
worry.  And with that congratulations the Astronify package is installed cool done.
First module or first section of this curriculum or this tutorial is checked
off the list. What I'm going to do now is I'm going to actually step away from the
terminal step away from some code and give you a little bit more theory about
what sonification is and how it works.  Now I've just mentioned sonification a
bunch of times here without actually saying anything about what it is so
we're gonna get into the theory we're gonna get into the examples and then
we'll get back to the code yeah. On that note I'm going to turn off the
speech for NVDA so it doesn't decide it wants to talk over me or talk over any
of the sonification examples which we did have a little bit of in the original
zoom so you know this is one a sound issue we will dodge. Speech mode off.
All right and with that we will get into what is this sonification thing. So in the
simplest terms sonification is the representation of data via sound. This is
directly analogous to data visualization where data is represented via some
visual medium.  These are your line charts your bar charts your pie charts
your histograms the list goes on there are a ton of data visualizations out
there. Importantly the data does not literally look this way it does not
literally look like a line graph it doesn't look like a bar chart this is
how we choose often to represent it through some visual medium. In fact
there are a lot of arbitrary choices involved in these in these visualizations
for instance you have a line chart how are you going to scale the axes how
large will you make the points these are all various different choices that you
can make in these data visualizations.  It is a representation of the data a way we
choose often to picture the data and oftentimes they're quite useful they let
us understand trends and things like that but there are issues with data
visualizations and not the least of which which will be of course great
interest to me and you is that they're not accessible to people with visual
impairments like me. So data sonification where we represent the
data as sound sort of corrects or steps around that one that sort of problem. Now
before we get more into data sonification and what exactly a
sonification could be besides the sound representation of data I want to break
down some common misconceptions about sonification.  First of all sonification
generally doesn't involve words so it's like non-speech audio so for instance me
standing here and telling you about data for instance when Patrick told you about
the Airbnb data set that is not a sonification it's just him telling you
about the about the data so it's not typically what we'd consider a
sonification a sound representation of the data it's like a word representation
of the data something along the lines of that I don't have a more elegant word
for that but it's not generally what we'd consider sonification. Sonification
also is not what we consider like natural sounds or or just the sounds
themselves. What do I mean by this? Well for instance imagine you have someone
walking and you are listening to their footsteps to understand to measure how
quickly they are walking.  In this case the sound of their footsteps is not a
sonification. The sound of their footsteps is the data so the sound is
not a representation of the data the sound in that case is the data. Scott
Fleming in his talk at the Space Telescope Science Institute's Day of
Accessibility had another great example bird songs not a sonification bird songs
would be your data if you were going out and observing bird songs same sort of
idea here.  So it is in the same way that a data visualization is not literally
like what the data looks like a data sonification is not literally what the
data sounds like. Alright so we've broken down roughly what sonification is it's
a sound representation of the data and it's not words and it's not sounds from
nature. Okay we've got the big picture here the only way to concretize this
sort of idea of what sonification is is going to be to get into how we actually
sonify things.  Today we're going to go over two of the most common sonification
techniques this is going to be modification and parameter mapping what
they are what their differences are and we'll also talk about some or we'll also
show some examples of each. Alright let's begin by talking about
modification. You'll often hear modification described as the most
direct mapping the most direct representation of data as sound.  What do
we mean by this? Well suppose we have two variables here X and Y and in this case
Y is our dependent variable which means that as X changes Y changes in response.
Now for our purposes here I'm going to say X is time so as time goes on Y
changes with time and so if Y is varying with time going up and down as time goes
by you can kind of imagine Y moving like in a regular wave not like a smooth wave
pattern but it's going up and down so Y the height of the wave is changing with
time. Now we call the height of a wave the amplitude and just as this height
this amplitude of Y is changing with time we can imagine the amplitude of a
sound wave changing with time at the same sort of way.  So basically if Y goes
up the amplitude the height of our sound wave goes up and if Y goes down the
amplitude or height of our sound wave goes down. So we are mapping the height
of Y to the height of the sound wave. This is what we mean by direct mapping
we're treating Y like it's a wave and then just making the sound wave that
represents Y behave in the exact same way as Y in terms of how it goes up and
down.  Now our ears perceive amplitude the height of the sound wave and again sound
is a wave in the air so our ears perceive the amplitude of a sound wave as the
volume it has to do with like this air pressure essentially you'll hear it as
changes in volume and so essentially what is happening is by going up and
down Y is controlling the value ofhsorry the volume of the sound wave we
hear representing the data. Alright so we've covered how the volume is
controlled by Y. What about pitch that's another really important part of sound
how high or low of note is. Well this comes down to something we call data
sampling.  We don't measure data continuously rather we have some sampling
rate which is often how we measure the data. So for instance I'm going to play
you some sounds from the accessible oceans project some modification from
the accessible oceans project and the times are measured each hour this is our
data sampling rate so we have like 24 measurements in a day one measurement
each hour. Likewise we don't play the sound continuously but rather we play it
at some data sampling rate where we play each note at an individual moment.  So we
have our data measurement rate or a data sampling rate and we have an audio
sampling rate where we play the rate at which we play the sounds. Now the
sampling rate or the frequency at which we measure and then play the
modification of data is analogous to sound frequency which our ears perceive
as pitch. Thus the frequency of the sound playback influences the pitch at which
we hear the modification.  Often we cannot play the modification of the data with
the same frequency as the original data sampling rate because the then the
frequency or the pitch we'd be playing would just be outside the audible
hearing range for humans. Thus in audification we often have to do
something that I've seen called translating or shifting the sound
representation of the data how the sampling rate at which we play notes
just so that the pitch is in the audible pitch range. Now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to play you a sonification of the tides from the accessible oceans
project at two different sampling rates.  It might be a little bit difficult to
hear over the recording like from my computer to your computer but there are
two different sampling rates and you can hear that there's a pitch difference
between the two. If you can't hear it through the recording I do encourage you
to go from the tutorial curriculum page to the accessible oceans page which is
linked there and has the examples on it. So if you can't hear the pitch difference
here definitely encourage you to go check that out.  I'm going to go play that
now so it'll be two sonifications.
All right that was pretty quick so I'm going to play that one more time.
All right hopefully you could hear the noise happening there.  That is the
tide cycle you're hearing. So tides go in and out you know every 24 hours that's
at least as much as I know about oceanography tells you what I know and
so what you're hearing is that actually every 24 samples not that we can hear
the individual nodes because they're so close together you hear that as the
tides going up and down control the volume of the modification going up and
down that each of those cycles is that 24 hour cycle of the tides going up and
down. Now I'm going to play this one more time the same modification before I
play the next one that's at a different sampling rate so you can hopefully hear
the two pitches side-by-side.
All right hopefully you can hear that on my end I can definitely hear the pitch
difference I'm hoping it comes through on the recording fingers crossed so what
you might have been able to tell on those two is first that whoop whoop whoop
is still there because we're still measuring that same tide or we're still
representing that same tide data of it going up and down the pitch is lower on
the second round of data and also it's a little bit slower it's a little bit
slower between each whoop whoop whoop and the modification lasts a little bit
longer because the data sampling the frequency at which we play those notes
is is a little bit slower which lowers that pitch and also lengthens the time of
the modification. So again hopefully you could hear that difference and if you
couldn't definitely recommend checking it out on your own computer. All right so
if modification is so straightforward we're treating the data like a wave and
then actually one second before I keep going I think the computer is about to
die rather than suffer another technical difficulty which should make
me quite sad I'm just going to plug this in sorry folks.  All right we're back
at business. Okay so if modification is so straightforward where we're really
just treating the data like a wave and then representing it as an analogous
sound wave why don't we do it for everything? Well there are a lot of
reasons. First it's pretty limited and what we can or cannot sonify.  For
instance how would you audify make an audification or a sonic
representation using audification of an image of some 2d data you know with an
X and a Y colors there are too many different parameters going on there to
put into this amplitude so this volume and then the time. So it's really better
suited for a very specific type of data a simpler type of data. Also there might
be other reasons we don't want to use audification for instance maybe there's
a more like aesthetically pleasing a nicer sound that we can use rather than
these amplitude changes in the sound wave.  An aesthetic difference is a really
valid reason to have a different representation of the data. I mean I can
say that I know a lot of scientists that spend a lot of time trying to make
their data visualizations look nice look pretty so that matters as a choice too
and it's a totally valid choice to make. Again we're not literally showing what
the data sounds like we're making choices of how to represent it and
depending on our audience and our goals we might make different choices.  So let's
get into what one of those different choices might be and that might be to
use a very popular and very flexible sonification technique called parameter
mapping. Parameter mapping is a more flexible as I mentioned form of
sonification that has become popular in the recent years and in parameter
mapping in essence we map or connect different aspects or dimensions of the
data to different parameters of the sound representation such as pitch or
volume and rhythm. Like modification we could use parameter mapping to sonify
data consisting of say one independent variable that's what I called Y and one
dependent variable that's what was time for us here but one of the strengths of
parameter mapping is that we can actually map much represent with sound
much more complex data than we can with modification because there are many
more aspects parameters to the sound that we can use that's pitch and rhythm
and volume different instruments and timber I'm not a musician but the list
goes on there are a lot of different knobs we can turn in our sound to
represent different dimensions different aspects of our data.  All right let's
clarify the concept of parameter mapping using an example suppose you
have measurements of number of sales of something I'm gonna go with ice cream
because I like ice cream I can totally go for some right now and net profits from
those sales of ice cream over a period of 50 years we choose to map the number
of sales to pitch such that more sales are represented by higher pitches and to
map net profits to volume such that more profits are represented by a louder
note so essentially we let pitch be mapped to sales and volume be
mapped to profits from those sales and now we're letting time that independent
variable what we'd have along you know the x-axis if this were a visualization
for any visualization folks we let time represent be represented by time in the
sonification such that each note is a measurement in time so that you know if
you're listening later in the sonification you know you're hearing
later in time so the first note represents 50 years ago and the last
note of the sonification represents the data measured now suppose as we listen
to the sonification that we hear a period in which the pitch of notes
drops so the pitch goes down we can tell from the mapping decisions that we made
that this means the number of ice cream sales in this period has dropped relative
to the other measurements perhaps it's wintertime or a recession and people
aren't buying as much ice cream now suppose that over the course of the
entire data sonification we hear the volume of notes generally increase but
the pitch remains relatively constant this means that profits have gone up but
the number of sales has gone has remained relatively constant so the cost
per ice cream sale the profit per ice cream sale must have gone up that's what
I'd call inflation finally suppose that the amount of time between notes
decreases towards the end of the sonification this might mean that the
data were collected more frequently in later times so that there's less time
between each data point note here that there is no one correct way to map our
data to different parameters we could just as easily have mapped sales to
volume and profits to pitch thus we make choices generally through testing and
experimentation to see which representations of our data most
effectively and most accurately capture the importance of information and
communicate of the information and communicate it preferably in a way
that's both understandable comprehensible and aesthetically pleasing
this is truly just no different from a data visualization where graphics will go
through many iterations of designs to clearly represent the data data
representations whether sonic or visual always represent choice so one of the
things I hear most often about sonifications is that they're arbitrary
is that you know this isn't you know there are so many different ways you
could represent the same data how do you ever know anything because that you
could just represent the data so many different ways but this is just how
representations of data in general go it involves choice it's kind of a fun thing
all right let's actually listen to a sonification or to a parameter mapping
example now because my background is in astronomy we're going to listen to an
astronomy example this is from the NASA and Chandra X-ray Center's universe of
sound website and what we're going to do is we're going to listen to the
sonification but it also comes with a description which tells us how the
break down the parameter mapping so what aspect of the data was mapped to
which a parameter of the sound and then we'll listen to the sonification all
right it's so we're going to listen to a sonification of the galactic center or
of data from the galactic center this was taken from the Chandra X-ray
telescope I believe explore the center of our very own Milky Way galaxy the
translation begins on the left side of the image and moves to the right with
the sounds representing the position and brightness of the sources all right
we've already got our first parameter mapping the translation begins on the
left side of the image and moves to the right they don't say this directly but
what this means is that time within the sonification is mapped to how far we are
moving from left to right in the image so you know if you hear in something
earlier in the sonification it's closer to the left you hear something right at
the end of the sonification later in time you know it's representing
something on the right of the image the light of objects located towards the top
of the image are heard as higher pitches while the intensity of the light
controls the volume all right that's two more parameter mappings there so pitch
is controlled by how far we are up and down the image with higher pitches
representing objects higher up in the image so closer to the top where lower
notes are going to represent objects lower down in the image we also have a
second parameter mapping in the sentence the intensity of the light
controls the volume what this means is that brighter objects are going to be
represented by louder noises and dimmer objects in the image are going to be
represented by softer noises stars and compact sources are converted to
individual notes while extended clouds of gas and dust produce an evolving
drone what does this mean well smaller objects are going to be little notes
larger objects longer sounds so the size of the object has to do with the duration
of the note the crescendo happens when we reach the bright region to the lower
right of the image this is where the 4 million solar mass supermassive black
hole at the center of our galaxy known as Sagittarius a star resides and where
the clouds of gas and dust are the brightest all right I'm gonna hit play
hopefully
right I love that sonification that's one of my favorites the universe of
sound project has lots of sonification so I definitely recommend checking it
out you can get a super long crash course into parameter mapping I think
they're lovely really lovely to listen to I'm biased because I like space but
there you have it I don't know about you but I think for me the easiest thing to
pick out is that note duration thing I could definitely hear those little chimes
that are representing stars and then the longer notes especially towards the end
where they told us that supermassive black hole is I can hear that sort of
longer stretch of notes really lovely I recommend if you want to go and listen
to that maybe several more times see if you can hear those individual
parameter mappings the pitch representing how high we are along the
image up or down the volume representing how bright something is I
definitely recommend that I think it also probably would be easier to hear
over your own computer again rather than through this recording I'm hoping
fingers crossed that the sound records much better here than it did for
everyone else sorry if you hear some background noise my guide dog is
standing up and shaking but I'm hoping it records much better than it did
during the original zoom all right so that is modification and parameter
mapping the two I would say most common sonification techniques you will
encounter that's also a really quick crash course into what sonification is
just keep in mind again sonification is a sound representation of the data now if
you're sitting here and thinking Sarah it's super pretty I think it's cool but
how in the world do you ever learn to interpret that very understandable and
especially it's understandable given that we think of data visualizations
graphs and charts and line graphs and so on and so forth as intuitive and easy
to interpret but that is not at all true children in schools spend years learning
to read graphs in the US where I'm from there's a standardized test for college
like to get into university called on the ACT and a whole section of the thing is
basically reading graphs and kids study for months for that so clearly we need
to learn to read and interpret data visualizations and there are studies
suggesting the same should be expected to be true of data sonifications that we
should expect to need to learn how to understand and interpret them this kind
of makes sense no one's born learning to read a data visualization no one's
born learning to understand like already knowing how to understand a data
sonification so our goal for the rest of this tutorial recording is going to be to
get some basic shapes in Python and then to sonify those different shapes with
that astronify package that we just installed in such a way that we can
sonify those different shapes and understand how they sound so you can
hear this is how a straight line sounds different from a curve which sounds
different from something that's moving in sort of a wave like shape the goal
here is to develop some intuition for you so things sort of make sense a
little bit more on a natural level so that next week when we get into
sonifying some more realistic data something that's not just shapes and
lines you'll have this intuition or at least the beginning of an intuition
already built so that's the goal for the rest of today so now we're going to
return to Anaconda prompt or maybe you're already sitting there and I'm
going to turn NVDA back on "speech mode beeps speech mode talk" and now we can
start IPython. So just as we have before I'm going to start IPython by
typing I P Y T H O N IPython no spaces and hitting enter. "Python 3.1 1.5
packaged by Anaconda Incorporated Main September." Alright I'm not gonna let it
play that whole thing through because I think you've heard it before but
essentially you'll know you're an IPython because it'll tell you your
Python version and eventually you'll get to it if you let it finish it'll tell
you we're in in one we're in the first input line. Now we're going to start by
making some of what I'm going to now refer to as synthetic or simulated data
what this basically means is not like real data from like observations or
measurements this is basically like fake data we've made to follow various shapes
or if you're math savvy and remember like your high school algebra classes
we're actually going to just be making some simple algebraic equations here
we're not actually going to go through making all of them we're going to go
through making several of them so you get the idea of like how this math is
going to work and then there's a CSV file that has everything already made
that you can load in from the URL I encourage you to go to the curriculum
it's under data preparation under the final subheading called just in case
quote onquote basically it gives you the CSV file in the URL and just gives you
the code to paste it in yes so I encourage you to do that but if you're
interested for how exactly all of that synthetic so again all of that not real
measured data was made in the CSV file the curriculum goes into painstaking
detail about how every column was made and exactly the equations that's going
into it so we'll kind of do a brief intro to that just so you have a rough
idea of how this CSV was made but if you want all the nitty-gritty details the
curriculum has everything all right so those of you who remember algebra
classes will remember that like functions equations have two different
variables what I've called independent or X and dependent Y so Y is a function of
X. Y is going to change when X changes so what I want to do first is I want to
make an array of numbers that's going to be our X values so imagine these all of
these values so I want for in our case I want 100 values evenly spaced from 0 to
10 so that at each value of X going from 0 to 0.1 0.2 0.3
whatever the the even spacing will be will have Y change a different value of
Y at each of those values and that Y will change differently depending on what
function we do now as was evidenced by the fact that I had to already sit and
think about like the first three numbers in those numbers ranging from 0 to 10 I
really don't actually want to sit here and write out a list or an array of a
hundred numbers evenly spaced from 0 to 10 I hope you don't want to do that
either I think we can all agree that that sounds really quite painful so the
good news is NumPy has a built-in function that will do this for us so
let's get started I'm going to start by importing our favorite packages here so
I'm going to do import NumPy import space NumPy and
"N-U-M-P-Y as NP" it's suggesting the way I always type NumPy but we're not
going to do that at the moment into all right and you can hear I hit enter and
now it's saying you're on the second line I'm gonna do import pandas "import
NumPy" it wants to repeat import NumPy we're not going to do that but we're not
gonna need pandas at the moment but we will need it very shortly so let's just
get it in here "I-M-P-O-R-T space P-A-N-D-A-S" import pandas in three whoo good news all
set and ready to go so what I've just done is brought the NumPy and pandas
packages into this coding session all right and next what we're going to do is
we're going to use something called the linspace function the linspace function
is a built-in function in NumPy that will basically give us an evenly spaced
array of numbers starting at a specified start number and ending at a specified
stop number I think this will be easiest to conceptualize if we actually do an
example so let's start by doing NumPy so "N-U-M-P-Y" so from NumPy so NumPy dot
dot NumPy dot linspace that's L-I-N-S-P-A-C-E so basically from the
NumPy package pull the linspace function open parenthesis I'm gonna do
0 comma 5 comma 5 close parenthesis. That's NumPy dot linspace
open parenthesis 0 comma 5 comma 5 that first 0 that's our start value for the
array the second number the 5 is the stop value for our array and then that
third number 5 is the number of values I want so basically what I'm saying is
linspace give me an array of numbers from 0 to 5 evenly spaced and I want
5 of them and when I hit enter it's going to return to me an array of those
numbers "out 3 array 0 1.25 2.5 3.75 5" yep there we go
and it has spit out an array that goes from 0 to 5 5 numbers evenly spaced
let's try this again we can change the parameters let's try NumPy dot linspace
"N-U-M-P-Y" dot linspace dot "L-I-N-S-P-A-C-E" "open parenthesis "left paren" I'm gonna go
0 comma 10 comma 5 what is this saying it's saying our
start our start value is 0 our stop value is 10 and I want 5 numbers so NumPy
dot linspace open parenthesis 0 comma 10 comma 5 close parenthesis give me 5
numbers evenly spaced from 0 to 10 "out 4 array 0 2.5 5 7.5 10" and now you can
hear we get an array of numbers going all the way up to 10 this time now this
is almost what I said I wanted I wanted an array of numbers from 0 to 10 but I
wanted a hundred of them so this time we're just going to increase that third
value from 5 to a hundred so instead give me a hundred numbers evenly spaced
from 0 to 10 and also I don't want the computer to just spit it out at us I
actually want to save it so just as Patrick taught us to save variables this
time instead of just doing NumPy dot linspace I'm going to do X equals NumPy
dot linspace because I'm gonna say hey make this array of numbers from 0 to 10
100 of them and call it X. "X space equals space n u m p y dot l i n s p a c e left
paren 0 comma 0 comma 1 0 0 right paren" X equals NumPy dot linspace open
parenthesis 0 comma 10 comma 100 close parenthesis in 6 and there's no output
this time because we've just saved X but if we type X and hit enter X "X equals
NumPy dot" it wants to suggest that I repeat that same line from before I
don't want to repeat the same line I just want to hit X and hit enter "out 6
array 0 0.1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0.2 0 2 0 2 0 2 0.3 0" all right I'm not gonna let it go
through the whole thing but as you can hear it's spitting out a rather long
array of numbers that are relatively close together and it'll keep going all
the way up to 10 a hundred of them we don't want to listen to all of that or
at least I don't you're welcome to listen in your own time if you really
want to hear all hundred of those numbers but now we have checked that
indeed it's saved as X we have an array of numbers evenly spaced from 0 to 10
and a hundred of them so rather small spaces now I'm going to do something I'm
going to make one of these equations as an example so that you can see how
roughly I've made these sort of simple shapes we have going and then we'll load
the CSV so that we just have all of the data so what I'm going to do right now
is I'm going to make something called a sine function a sine of X so what I mean
by this is a sine function is a trig function a trigonometric function
basically it's a wave so as X increases Y responds to X by moving up and down in
an even wave pattern it just goes up and down at regular intervals as X goes up
so essentially what we are doing right now is we are making a wave shape and I
just want to call this Y because this is how we often do this in math classes so
I'm going to actually I'm going to call it Y underscore sine to specify that we
are making a like a sine function it's always good to like name your variables
in such a way that you know what they mean because here why if I just call Y
it could be like any function if I call Y underscore sine we know it's a sine
like a sine wave so we are making a wave right now one Y any line so Y
underscore S I N E that's how we spell sine for for you know in math it's not
like a sign like a street sign yes. so y_sine
"space equals space" um and fortunately NumPy so sine is like
non easy math thing to do like a multiplication it's something you
generally want a calculator for fortunately NumPy has a built-in sine
function so all we have to do is do NumPy dot it's actually sin so it's not
a full sign it's NumPy dot s i n and that's NumPy's sine function and you
... that was a typo it should be NumPy
dot sign not NumPy parenthesis dot s i n left for n right now we want that left
for n so Y underscore s i n e equals NumPy dot s i n open parenthesis 2 times
X that's going to be "2 star X right paren" so we are saying that
Y sine is equal to the sine of 2 times X again this is a really powerful thing
about NumPy arrays that you can do math with them like this you can multiply them
you can take the sine of them all sorts of things like this and we can hit enter
and if we print out Y sine now so if I just type Y underscore sine "Y line s i n
e and hit enter out a array 0 0.20064886 0.39313661 0.56963411 0.72296256 0.84688556
0.93636273 0.98775469 0.99897117 0.969555" sorry to play so many of those numbers for
you but I wanted you to hear that it goes up and then back down if I let it play even
longer we would have heard it go all the way down below zero and then back up again
which I encourage you to do because it'll give you an intuition for what's going on
with this function but essentially what I want you to understand is that a sine of X
is a wave so it's going to go up and then down and then up again and then down again
all right cool let's make maybe one more really quite simple equation here I in fact it's
going to be the simplest equation it's going to be a linear equation we're going to make
Y equals X which basically means that for every step X makes to get larger Y gets larger
by the same amount and I'm going to call this Y underscore linear Y Y line linear Y underscore
L I N E A R "L I N E A R space equals space" and it's just Y equals X so Y underscore linear
equals X and that's basically saying it's like a straight line just slanted upwards
every step X gets bigger Y gets bigger by the same amount in 10 and if we output Y underscore
linear "1 L I N E A R out 10 array 0 0.1010101 0.2020202 0.3030" all right I'm going to stop
it there but maybe you remember from when we printed out X that this is exactly the same
so basically we've just gone and we've made a an array that makes the exact same that
is exactly the same as X so every step X gets bigger Y stays the same amount so it gets
bigger by the same amount it is a straight line now again if you go to the curriculum
it goes through in absolute detail how to make every single one of the equations that
we're going to load into the CSV and so if you're mathematically minded or you just want
to learn more about how to do math in Python I definitely encourage you to check that out
it covers quadratic equations all sorts of things like that but we're not going to get
into all of that right now just because I know it's a little bit tedious and everything's
already loaded into a CSV so if you're more on the data analysis side of things you don't
want to do all the math then we don't have to get into all of that maybe yeah so I encourage
you to check out the curriculum either at this moment to see the rest of the math happen
or to load the CSV which I'm about to do I actually with the benefit of hindsight I would
love to show you guys how to do a quadratic equation as well just because I want to show
you guys how to do an exponent maybe this is the math person in me showing so I'm just
going to show you how to do a quadratic really quickly now this isn't actually the exact
quadratic that I have in the CSV I've sort of shifted and compressed that a little bit
just to make it a nicer shape to listen to and again the curriculum goes into painstaking
detail about how exactly that goes but I just want to show you how to do an exponent so
a parabola is the shape of a quadratic equation it's basically a curve that goes up up up
really steep as you get to the turning point it sort of starts to level out it turns around
and then gets steeper and steeper as it goes back down or up again depending on whether
or not you flipped it so it's almost like a wave but it's not like the sign because the
sign goes up and down repeatedly the parabola is just a curve that turns over once and it's
steepest at the sides and flattest at the top and it's the simplest form of a quadratic
is y equals x squared I'm going to save this as an equation that or as a variable that I'm
going to call y underscore parabola because that is the shape of a quadratic so it's going to be
y underscore "y underscore p a r a b o l a"
parabola space equals space x squared and the the main reason that I am taking the time
to do this right now even though it's all in that csv is that I want you guys to know how to do
exponents in I want to recap how to do exponents in Python just in case because I think it's good
to know so I always when I started doing Python expected an exponent to be a caret it is not it
is two asterisks so x squared is x asterisk asterisk square two "x star star two" so y parabola
equals x asterisk asterisk two in 12 and if we print out y parabola just by typing it and hitting
enter "y line p a r a b o l a out 12 array 0.000000000 e plus 00 1.02030405 times" we
had some crazy numbers I don't I don't find that easy to interpret I don't know about you I think
they're all in a scientific notation that's what that e means that it's put it you know in the form
of so for instance 9e2 would be 9 times 10 to the power of 2 which is 200 not 200 is 100 sorry
about that so 9 times 100 or 900 it's what we do for like really large or small numbers in science
and Python loves to print things out like that sometimes if it gets a little unwieldy I don't
know about you but I find that a little bit difficult to interpret just listening to it
scientific notation is a little bit hard to interpret just hearing it or looking at it I
would say but the thing to keep in mind again is that a parabola a quadratic equation is that curve
shape going up and then down just once and if you want to see the exact way I did this to make it
in the CSV then again check out the curriculum it goes into absolute detail about how I made this
this CSV so you can have all the nitty-gritty you can know the exact equation I used for everything
and again if you're curious about that feel free to stop by office hours or shoot me an email
all right I'm going to pop out of um out of ipython and into uh into google chrome
...
and because I am low vision I am well accustomed to squinting at my computer so you might notice
me navigating in a way that is a little bit more sighted than maybe um just fully using NVDA that's
also...me not being a full NVDA desktop I usually use mac
so one little caveat if you are working from uh the curriculum as it is now there's one little
thing we're going to need to do before we copy and paste that little snippet of code again this is
under that subheading just in case in the module preparing data for sonification now I have done
a little shorthand in this code snippet that in retrospect I shouldn't know so I might go back and
fix it but basically I am very accustomed to shortening pandas as pd you'll see people do
this a lot it's just because it's shorter to type out than pandas but we have to tell our computers
like hey I'm going to call pandas pd from now on so we've already imported pandas but we're actually
going to import it again and tell the computer actually from now on I'm going to call it pd
so that's just import "I M P O R T "import pandas "space p a n d a s" as pd space "a s pd"
import pandas as pd so bring in pandas and from now on we're calling it pd again we've already
brought in pandas we're into this ipython session but now we need to remind the computer tell the
computer hi I'm calling it something different now we only need to do this just because if you
copy and paste straight from the code I put in the curriculum I call pandas pd there which
was an oversight on my part so I might go back and fix that I probably ought to so I'm going to hit
enter importing all right we've imported pandas as pd and now I am just going to paste in that
line of code or those three lines of code actually um from uh oh actually there's one other thing we
need to cover before we paste in those lines of code and that's going to be uh something called
um astropy tables now astronify the sonification package that we are using today is a package that
was made by astronomers to be used by astronomers and we'll get into more detail about what exactly
it is and how it works in a second but because it was made by astronomers for astronomers um it uses
a specific type of data a object type in python that astronomers like to use this is something
called an astropy table astropy is astropython basically it is a python package that has a ton
of astronomy functionalities things like astronomy units like things like light years and parsecs
it also has coordinate system transforms all sorts of things like that are handled within
astropy it also has a data type actually there's multiple but in this case it has this uh this type
um of object called a table for our purposes here an astropy table is exceptionally similar
to an astro uh to um a panda's data frame and in fact they're so similar that astropy has a built
in function to uh convert a panda's data frame directly to an astropy table um and the reason
we're going to do this is because um the reason we want to do this is because uh um astronify only
takes as input astropy tables it really just wants astropy tables because it was made for astronomy
data so we have to convert our panda's data frame to an astropy table in order to give it to um
in order to give it to astronify to sonify so what i'm going to do here is i'm going to import
table from astropy so basically say from this astropy package bring in this table things we
need it so i'm going to type from "f r o m" so from astropy that space that's "a s t r o p y"
dot table "dot t a b l e" so from the subsection of astropy called table space import "i m p o r t"
so from astropy dot table import table except here table is capitalized "space T a b l e" so from
astropy table import table and again the table that second table so not astropy dot table but
that table after import that's got to be a capital t there "in 15" all right and it's imported we've
brought the table thing in so if i bring in these lines of code i'm just going to copy and paste
those three lines of code in from under just in case um i'm sorry to all of you guys watching on
the recording that i'm not reading this out it is just a horrendously long url um maybe should
i read it out oh no i i'm gonna i'm gonna really encourage you guys to go and copy and paste this
from the uh from the curriculum or maybe we can put it in the description of this youtube video
um because i think me reading it out loud right now is just going to lead to some suffering and
also to uh just mistyping it i don't think it's going to be very helpful but there are three
lines in this code the first line that we're going to copy and paste in is url equals that really
long url it's basically hey the url is called this save it as this thing called url the second
one is a function we've seen before it's df equals pd dot read csv url so it's basically saying
make a new data frame called df and then pd remember that's now pandas pandas dot read csv
so read the csv at that url after url it's comma index underscore call equals
zero that means set the index of our new data frame as the zeroth column and then the third
and final line of code is tbl equals table so capital t table that's the table we just imported
from astropy dot from pandas open parenthesis df close parenthesis what that's saying is make
a new table call it tbl and make it from the pandas data frame that we've named df all right
now i'll finally stop yammering and copy and paste that in well i've already copied it warning
dialogue warning you are about to paste text that command prompt terminal ipython
i trust uh it was asking whether or not i trusted that copy and paste that was putting in and and i do
trust it because that's my own url this is the moment we cross our fingers that uh it's gonna
work um again first line is the url "e slash sonification e selected main slash prepared
data dot csv raw equals true selected slash url equal" that's it reading that part of the url that's
that first line "df equals selected space selected pd dot read csv url index co l equals zero selected"
all right and that's it reading the second line df equals pd dot read underscore csv
open parenthesis url that's the url from the first line comma comma index underscore call
equals zero and then finally that last line "tbl equals t selected i selected
...that wasn't very helpful that
that final line is tbl equals table capital t dot from pandas open parenthesis df close
parenthesis so make a make a table from the panda's data frame df and call it tbl i'm gonna hit enter
and cross our fingers that it works "in 16." all right no error messages read out that means it
worked success all right our data is prepared it is in an astropy table let's take a moment
to explore this astropy table so first what we're going to do is we're going to print out
the column names the way we do this for an astropy table is by doing tbl so that's the
name of our table t b l and then we're going to do dot call dot ... it's already trying to
suggest it dot c o l n a m e s tbl dot col names so from table take
the column names and if we hit enter it'll just print them out "out 16 x linear n e g linear
parabola abs sine in 17." all right so in this table there are six columns there is x linear
neg underscore linear parabola abs and sine these are the x actually the exact same x that we made
with that lin space function above and then five other functions of x so variables that are
following a function of x linear is that y equals x that we made above so it's just every step that
x makes to get bigger y gets bigger by the same amount so it's a straight line going up neg
underscore linear is y equals negative x so it's still a straight line except every time that x gets
bigger y gets smaller so it's a straight line slanted downwards parabola that's the quadratic
equation we were talking about now in this case it's not exactly y equals x squared it's a little
bit different um i believe it's something like if i recall correctly i want to say it's let me take a
look y equals negative times the quantity x minus five squared plus one um if any of you are algebra
people if not don't worry about it essentially what we care about here is not so much the math
as the shape so we understand the shape we're going to represent with sound and remember this
is a curve that goes up up up up new notification no no no no sorry um someone's notification um
okay um what we care about here is that parabola is a curve that goes up really steep then as it
starts to turn over it gets a little bit flatter stays flat turns over gets steeper again going
down absolute value what i've called abs abs that is a function that goes up up up and then very
sharply turns back down so it's a straight line slanted upwards kind of like our y equals x and
then it very sharply turns around and goes slanted downward in a straight line like our y equals
negative x and then finally sine that is our wave so y equals sine of x so that y goes up and down
at regular intervals in a wave as x gets bigger all right so those are our six columns of the
table next let's just take a look at what's inside one of those columns and the way we're going to
call one of the columns uh of the table is a little bit different than the syntax you've been
using with patrick to call the columns of the panda's data frames i believe we're going to do
tbl tbl so from table what we've called our tbl that's the name of our table open square bracket
left bracket x it's already trying to suggest uh what we're going to do open bracket we're going
to do quotation mark x quotation mark and then close square bracket so it's tbl
open square bracket uh quotation mark x quotation mark close square bracket so basically um in x
or in table we're calling the column called x which is saved in quotation marks uh sort of like
how we do for pandas data frames they've they've got quotation marks around because they're a string
they're they're a word and then if we hit enter "out 17 less column name equals x type equals
float 64 length equals 100 greater 0.0 0.1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0.2 0 2 0 2 0 2 0 2 0 2"
all right i'm gonna stop that there um i don't think we need to listen to the whole thing but
you might have noticed it was a little different at the beginning from how a panda's data frame
prints out um a column uh but it tells you there's a column the column name is called x
it tells you that it's a float which means it's decimal numbers tells you the length of the
column i actually don't i guess i wasn't paying enough attention hopefully it said 100 there
because there should be 100 numbers and then again if you remember from before those are the same
numbers that were in our x array that we got from numpy dot linspace so phew this astropy table has
preserved the data that we made and again the um and then that we put in that csv and again the
curriculum goes through in detail every step of how we made this synthetic so again this not real
data to represent shapes put it in a data frame and then get it into this astropy table that we
now have awesome so we know which columns are in our pen or in our astropy table and we've checked
on one of the columns to make sure that it's a new notification from oh this is new note of
sorry about that folks i am uh i'm borrowing a friend's laptop to do this since i
am a mac user primarily um and in fact i don't even know how to put a windows laptop on do not
disturb so we might have some notifications coming in um hopefully not too many um okay moving
onwards um so we've checked on this astropy table we've made sure it doesn't look fishy
kind of is behaving for our purposes an awful lot like a panda's data frame that's good news
that is all we really need to care about and with that we are going to uh check off that data
preparation stage and celebrate because we are about to get into actually sonifying things
with one caveat first i want us to talk about what astronify is and how it works
all right so astronify is a python package we've installed that is developed by scott
fleming at the space telescope science institute clara brosser at space telescope science institute
and now at the university of saint andrews um jen kotler at space telescope and kate meredith
at glass education and it is a package designed to sonify or represent a sound a very specific
type of astronomical data called a light curve light curves represent the observed amount of
light from an object typically a star as we see it on earth so it observe it measures the amount
of light we see um generally from a telescope so how much light we are collecting from a telescope
from a specific star over time astronomers like to call that observed amount of light how much
light we receive from an object here on earth we like to call that flux so we are observing the
flux the amount of light seen from a star over time thus light curves allow astronomers to
observe variability in the amount of light a telescope records coming from a star or to
record how bright a star basically appears to us on earth observing this variability can give
insight into all sorts of incredible phenomena including explosive stellar activity called flares
so that would be a sudden increase in brightness at a period of time and small periodic dips in
the amount of light observed from a star caused by a planet orbiting that star and blocking some
of its light as it passes through our line of sight and orbits the star um as it passes through
our line of sight with the star we call this latter phenomenon a an exoplanet transit and
we've used it to discover thousands of planets outside our solar system orbiting other stars
what's essentially happening is that at regular intervals as the planet orbits the star
it gets in between our telescope and the star and blocks a tiny fraction of the light and it does
that over and over and over again so you know if you see a star that looks like it's getting dimmer
by a tiny regular amount at regular intervals you can be like there might be a planet getting
in the way there and boom you found a planet. Astronify works by mapping the observed flux
again remember that's the observed amount of light we see from the star that's our dependent
variable that's changing with time to pitch such that higher fluxes are represented by higher
pitches so if you have a moment where you observe more light that data is going to be represented by
a higher pitch each observation of the star's brightness is thus represented by a note where
the pitch is controlled by the value of that observation it is worth noting here that although
it's the default to have brighter like higher fluxes brighter moments brighter data points
mapped to higher pitches the user can set a parameter within Astronify to invert the pitches
such that higher fluxes more light are mapped to lower pitches there might be you know personal
preference reasons you might do that. We might get into discussing parameters involved in Astronify
sonifications next week and this will hopefully make some more sense with some more examples
so I'm going to once again going to turn off NVDA's speech mode so it doesn't talk over the
sonifications speech mode off speech mode beeps nope I don't want it on speech mode off all right
and I'm going to go to Astronify's example this is straight from their web page I highly recommend
that you check out Astronify's web page it's again linked on the curriculum um it's a really
incredible project I think it's great so I highly recommend you check it out and I'm going to play
something this is a sonification of a light curve containing a stellar flare
did you hear that I'm going to play that one more time
so
the sound stays relatively constant until boom there's this moment of where it gets
way higher pitched and we know from the mapping we've just discussed that that higher pitch
is representing a moment where the star gets a lot brighter as we see it and that's the flare
a flare of light and activity from the star that we can really clearly hear as a change in the pitch
of the sound representation of the data all right cool now as a concept check
moving uh thinking back to our discussion of modification and parameter mapping
do you think that Astronify is parameter mapping or modification I'll wait for a second
it's awkward to like wait and and give you a chance to think about it when there's like no
one on like a zoom call with me or anything I'm just sort of like yes I sit in uh I sit in silence
and I uh I let people hopefully online think about it okay that's probably enough time um so
Astronify is parameter mapping because in this case the flux or how high y goes up or down
our independent or our dependent variable it goes up or down is mapped to pitch so it's not
controlling the amplitude of the sound wave which remember we perceive generally as volume
it's controlling the pitch so that is a parameter mapping where we have mapped the flux to the
parameter pitch in our sonification all right now here we've discussed Astronify within the context
of its intended use sonifying light curves however light curves are just the type of 1d data or what
I would call 1d data in astronomy so we have two variables time and flux x and y I suppose
mathematicians might tell me that they're actually two dimensions 2d because it's time and flux those
are two dimensions I'm going to call it 1d variable um hopefully there are no mathematicians who are
going to like hunt me down for this but there are all kinds of 1d data out there including maybe
some data that you've uh you've dealt with before so we can realistically present other 1d data
using Astronify beyond just light curves but before we get to all that complicated stuff
let's go back to that sonification education point we were getting back before and this was
inspired by a talk that Scott Fleming one of the developers of Astronify gave at the Space
Telescope Science Institute's Day of Accessibility wherein he talked about
about sonification education and gave some examples where we sonify um where we where he
sonified with Astronify some of these simple shapes very similar to what we're about to do
so now we're going to make our own sonifications you're going to get a sense for what Astronify
does all right I'm going to turn my volume down a little bit so I don't blast our ears out with uh
with NVDA "speech mode speech mode talk" I'm going to turn the volume up uh I'm going to turn the
volume up hopefully not too much hopefully that's a reasonable amount of volume we'll hope for the
best okay we've installed Astronify but we haven't imported it into this Python session so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to write from "F-R-O-M" from Astronify that's "A-S-T-R-O-N-I-F-Y.series"
it wants to finish for me but I've like finished the sentence or finished the line for me but I'm
not gonna let it from Astronify A-S-T-R-O-N-I-F-Y dot series "dot s-e-r-i-e-s" so from the subsection
of Astronify series import so space "space i-m-p-o-r-t" import and we're going to import
a function called Soni series that is capital s so capital S-o-n-i-series capital S-e-r-i-e-s
so the s in sauna and the s beginning series are capitalized from Astronify series from
dot series import sauna series "wx python is not found for the current python version
pyo will use a minimal gui toolkit written with tkinter if available this toolkit has
limited functionalities and is no more maintained or updated if you want to use all of pyos"
all right so I just let it play some of a warning that came out I think a lot of people have been
getting this warning I've been getting this warning I think Patrick did as well I heard
from some other people from the live class that they got this warning nothing to worry about it's
just like a little warning maybe bad advice but I often ignore warnings if it's not an actual error
message so maybe don't take that to heart but I just wanted you to hear it so that if you hear
it on your computer you don't worry it's no biggie and now we're going to get started with
the sonification now this is going to involve inherently some kind of repetitive four lines
of code I'm going to go through the first time or two relatively slowly but then I encourage you
and then I'm going to get faster just to you know so we don't take too much time it's again all of
these lines of code are on the online curriculum so if you get lost if I start moving too quickly
at some point just go and copy and paste it because it's all a little bit repetitive it's
like the same thing with like one word changed so there's no shame in like copying and pasting as
long as you understand what's going on and couldn't do it yourself afterwards but most programmers
copy and paste so what we're going to do first is make an instance of a soni series so the sauna
series is a class we're going to make a soni series object I'm going to call it soni underscore
linear "s o n i" underscore linear " l i n e a r" soni underscore linear and I'm going to
do equals space equals and I'm going to do um and the reason I'm calling it soni linear is because
this is going to be the sonification object the sauny series object for a linear equation so
remember that's our straight line going up "space s o n i s e r i e s" remember that's
all one word with the s in soni and the s in series both capitalized then open parenthesis
tbl so make a soni series object from our table which we've called tbl now there are
two extra things we need to do here in this function and that is we need to say hey astronify
I know you're made for astronomers sonifying light curves but um actually so I know that you expect
these time columns and value columns to be like time and flux but actually we don't have time
and flux we have like x and linear that's the name of our columns so we're just going to tell
soni series hey expect time call the time column to be x and val call to be linear the value column
so that's tbl comma space time "t i m e" underscore c o l "line c o l" equals "equals"
open quotation mark x close quotation mark so say the time call is our x column that's the name that
we printed out above when we checked the column names in tbl comma "comma" space "space" and then the
value column which is val col "v a l" underscore "line c o l" c o l equals "equals" quotation mark
linear "l i n e a r"close quotation mark close parenthesis soni underscore linear
equals soni series with the s's capitalized open parenthesis tbl comma time underscore c o l
equals open quotation mark x quote close quotation mark comma v a l underscore c o l
equals open quotation mark linear close quotation mark close parenthesis here's the next line well
we haven't actually played anything we've just made the object there's another little step I
want to take I want to say hey sonification um make the notes kind of a wider spacing and this
is something I've played around with already um and a choice that I've made again remember how
data representations involve a lot of choice I'm increasing the note spacing here from the default
just so it's a little bit slower and easier to hear so the way we're going to do it is we're
going to do soni_linear
the thing we just made dot note underscore spacing dot n o t e that's note n o t e underscore
space equals "space equals" space and I'm going to set it to 0.05 this is something that I have
in advance tested and decided is a good note spacing for us again choices we can make "0.05"
all right sonny underscore linear dot note spacing equals 0.05 in 21 all right we've
changed the note spacing now we're going to do soni underscore linear "s o n i" underscore linear
"line l i n e a r" dot sonify that means make the sound representation of this thing "s o n i...
one" open parenthesis close parenthesis because it's a function but we don't have any
parameters we want to put in so sonny underscore linear dot sonify make the sonification make the
sound representation "in 22" and the last thing we need to do is soni underscore linear dot play
open parenthesis close parenthesis
all right and this is the moment where I will once again turn off NVDA so it doesn't talk at us
um you might get a warning that says like port MIDI closed that's what NVDA is going to try to
read for me if you get that warning uh don't worry about it um but I have uh "speech mode" off I've
turned off speech mode I'm going to turn up my volume and I'm going to hit enter and it will play
our sonification before we start again remember what we're sonifying we're sonifying the shape
of a straight line slanted upwards so as time as x gets bigger we should expect y to get bigger and
remember y is mapped to pitch I'm going to play that again I'm just typing that same line again
exact same thing just so I can play it a second time
okay can you hear that the pitch gets higher and higher in a sort of straight line as we move along
in time which is the same as moving along along that value you might hear this sort of
this sort of wobble that's just because there's like a little bit of a spacing
again that's actually the spacing I've done between the notes where I've spread them out
where there's a little bit of space but some overlap between the notes and your ears hear
that as like kind of a wobble in the noise but the pitch in general is going up in a straight line
representing that straight line speech mode speech mode talk all right NVDA is back on
turn the volume back down so we don't hurt my ears here
okay we've got plenty of time so that's good let's sonify our negative linear equation so
that's the straight line slanted downwards and I'm going to this is the exact same lines of
code except instead of calling it sonny linear I'm going to call it sonny underscore neg underscore
linear and instead of the value column being linear it's going to be neg underscore linear
which is the name of that negative line column in the table so let's repeat those same four lines
of code "s o n i line n e g line l i n e a r space equals" so soni underscore s o n i underscore neg
underscore linear equals space soni series s o n i again remembering those capital s's s e r i
e s soni series again take open quote or open parenthesis tbl make a soni
series from our table tbl "comma time call space i m e line c o l" sorry that should be time call
that k was an accident time call so remember it expects the x-axis the independent variable to be
called time we've called it "equals tick x tick" we've called it x "comma" and our val col space a
"l line c o l" our value column equals in this case is neg linear tick "n e g line l i n e a r tick"
right paren sonny underscore neg underscore linear equals sauna series open parenthesis
tbl comma time underscore col equals open quotation mark x close quotation mark
comma val underscore call equals open quotation mark neg underscore linear
close quotation mark close parenthesis make us on a series object from the table call it
soni neg linear where the time column is x and the value column is neg linear "in 25."
all right we're going to once again change the note spacing "s o n i line n e g line l i n e a r"
sonny underscore neg underscore linear dot notice underscore spacing "dot n o t e line s p a c i n g
space" so soni underscore neg underscore linear dot note underscore spacing equals "equals space"
0.05 "0.05" that's the same as we did before "in 26" and then remember those last two lines "s o n i"
soni underscore neg underscore linear "line s s n e g line l i n e a r" soni underscore neg
underscore linear dot um sonify "s o n i f y left and right paren" open and close parenthesis we don't have
anything in them sonny underscore neg underscore linear dot sonify parentheses in 27 and then the
last line is that sonny underscore neg underscore linear dot play open quote or open parenthesis
close parenthesis "s o n i line n e g line l i n e a r dot p l a y left right paren"
and i'm going to turn off nvda again "speech mode off" and i'm going to turn the volume up
and you can hear the pitch starts high and goes low let's play that again i keep expecting to hear
nvda like read the line because i'm typing the same line again right now to play it again um and
i expected to speak to me but of course i just turned speech off so um jokes on me i guess that's
my own fault soni underscore neg underscore linear to play it again
excellent all right i'm going to do one more thing you can hear again it goes much in the
same way that sonny linear went up in a straight line here the pitch goes down in a linear fashion
it goes down in a straight line with time because this is representing a line slanted downwards
all right let's um i'm gonna do one more thing i'm gonna do soni underscore linear dot play so
you can hear that just sort of side by side so this is that straight line slanted up
sonny underscore linear dot play just to play that straight line slanted upwards this time
cool can you hear that yeah it's going up the pitch goes up this time instead of down i feel
like i can almost like feel it going up um maybe that's sort of a weird thing to say maybe i've
just listened to a lot of astronify uh sounds um it's kind of fun and spacey i like these they
kind of feel like aliens in a fun way i like it um all right i'm going to turn speech mode back
and i'm going to remember to turn the volume down so we don't like pain anyone
all right and what i'm going to do next is i'm going to sonify
the sine wave function remember that is um our wave that goes up and down y equals sine of x it's
a wave that goes up and down now we are again this is the same four lines of code where we
make the sauna series object we change the note spacing we sonify it and we hit play and uh just
with those couple of little differences but because it's so similar i'm going to start moving
a little quicker again all of this code is on the curriculum online feel free to copy and paste
if you you know feel the need um i understand but also make sure you understand what's going on so
this time i'm going to call it soni underscore sine "s-i-n-e s-o-n-y line l-i-n-e" l've called
it sonny line i actually want to call it soni sine "s-i-n-e" all right soni underscore s-i-n-e
"equals space" equals Soni Series with those capital s's
open parenthesis tbl comma space time call
underscore equals x in quotation marks
x comma val col a underscore c o l equals sine because that's the name of the column
with the sign function in our table and again if you don't remember you can always just do tbl dot
col names and hit enter to print out the list of column names in your table if you need to check
"s-i-n-e tick" and again remember sign is in quotation marks and it's spelled s-i-n-e
and close the parenthesis or it'll throw an angry "in 31"
changing the note spacing soni dot sine "line" soni underscore sine sorry not soni dot sine
dot note spacing underscore spacing
"s-p-a-c-i-n-g" space equals 0.05 "0.05"
soni underscore sine dot note underscore spacing equals 0.05 just move the notes a little further apart
"in 32" soni underscore sine dot sonify
"s-o-n-i-line s-i-n-e dot s-o-n-i-f-y"
son underscore sign dot sonify "left paren right paren" make those parenthesis "in 33"
hit enter sonny underscore sign s-o-n-i-line s-i-n-e dot play
and we will do the same business of increasing the volume
and turning off nvda "speech mode off" and hitting enter
oh
that one's a lot more fun right i think that one's a lot more exciting than the straight lines
you can hear the
as the as that wave goes up and down so as y gets higher and then lower higher and then lower
the pitch goes up and down and up and down at regular intervals i'm gonna play that one again
actually because i really quite like that one so i'm just typing that same line sonny underscore
sign dot play cool that's our sine wave we've played two different lines one going up one
going down and we've also played our sine wave let's turn the volume back down "speech mode
talk" all right there are just two more functions to sonify here they are our quadratic or our
parabola so again that's the curve that starts steep turns over once a little bit smoother at
the top and then uh turns back downwards and gets really steep again and then also our absolute
value function which um goes up in a straight line very sharply turns back around and goes right back
down the goal here is i want to sonify these two i'm going to play them actually side by side so
i'm going to make both sonifications wait to play them until they're side by side because i want you
guys to learn to hear the difference between a sharp turnaround and a more gradual turnaround
so a more gradual turnaround in our parabola which is a smoother curve and then a really sharp
turnaround in the absolute value and again we're going to move a little quickly through the code
here so feel free to copy and paste or to check the curriculum if you need to so that's so i'm
going to call this soni underscore parabola
space equals space and then it's Soni Series not forgetting those
capital s's open the parenthesis table time underscore col equals, equals x
with x in quotation marks another comma space val_col =
here it is called 'parabola' is the name of the column
"in 36" all right we've made our parabola sauna series we're gonna change the note spacing "s o
n i line p a r a b o l a dot n o t e line s p a c i n g" soni underscore parabola dot note underscore
spacing space equals space 0.05 "0.05" same as before just doing
that because that's what i tested and i think sounds best feel free to change that note spacing
make it bigger or smaller and see what you think "in 37" again that's tweaking with uh with the
parameters of the sonification to see what you prefer again full of choices then soni underscore
parabola "s o n i line p a r a b o l a" dot sonify so make the sound representations
and i'm gonna hit enter but i'm not gonna do um soni underscore parabola dot play just yet
because again i want to sonify the absolute value thing at the thing function at the same time
so let's do that really quick i'm going to call that sonny underscore abs abs because
sonny underscore absolute underscore value sounds really painful to type out so abs
soni_abs =
SoniSeries with the capital s space "s o n i s e r i e s" soni series
open the parenthesis tbl comma time_col='x'
remembering our quotation marks
val_col made a typo there v a l underscore c o l i feel like that's kind
of easy to make a typo on equals abs because that's also what the name of that column is
because i guess i never wanted to type absolute value so i just called everything abs
so soni underscore abs equals sauna series open parenthesis tbl
comma time underscore call equals open tick or open quotation mark um x close quotation mark
comma val underscore call equals open quotation mark abs close quotation mark close parenthesis
"in 39" soni underscore abs dot note spacing we're changing the note spacing s o n i dot a b s
nope i did i did soni i did soni dot abs i meant to do soni underscore abs
nope i did space i'm gonna do soni underscore abs dot note spacing sorry my brain
is apparently leaving me "dot n o t e line s p a c i n g" soni underscore abs dot note underscore
spacing equals 0.05 all right importing and then sonny underscore abs
dot sonify open and close the parenthesis and now we can play
the parabola so that smooth curve going up and then turning around going down next to the
absolute value which is that sharp turnaround like the top of a triangle so first i'm going to do
the uh i'm going to do the parabola that's soni underscore parabola dot play
soni underscore parabola dot play open and close in the parenthesis
and again turning off nvda "speech mode off" turning up the volume and hitting enter oh no
we have an error "speech mode beeps speech mode talk" this is terrible
"line a b s dot p l a left right paren pio warning port midi closed in 43"
interesting um i got an error when i tried to play the parabola but the uh the absolute value
seems to have played let me try the uh let me try the parabola again...
...that's soni underscore parabola dot play open parenthesis
close parenthesis i'm going to turn off nvda and hope it works this time "speech mode off"
all right i guess it will work this time i guess it was just angry before i'm going to turn nvda
back on so i can play the absolute value again "speech mode beeps speech mode talk" that's going
to be soni underscore abs "speech mode off"
so that's sonny underscore abs dot play
you're going up up up up up and then suddenly changing and going back down at a constant rate
let me play the parabola one last time so you can hear them side by side again
again that's sonny underscore parabola dot play open and close the parenthesis
it's a much slower change to the pitch turning and going back down we are literally hearing
the difference in those shapes a sharp versus a slow turnaround i encourage you to play that
often on your end just until you get that sound for the feeling for it and again play all of the
sonifications again and again i'm going to play the sign again sonny underscore sign dot play
we can hear that wave pattern going up and down that we don't have in that absolute value or the
parabola the there's more turnarounds in the pitch going up and down than we have in those other two
shapes so again the goal here is to develop an intuition for what astronomy is doing and how
different shapes how different behaviors of our data because again this is all about a representation
of the data it's what is this y doing as x changes which we have represented as what is the pitch
doing as time changes it's developing this intuition for what is going to happen to our
data representation for different types of data behavior that is the goal here that is all about
what this education process is about this is what we teach people to do with data visualization for
years and what we're just developing an intuition for now this is where i'm going to conclude the
fourth tutorial from this non-visual data science tutorial series this is the first of two
sonification tutorials and the fourth of five total tutorials so next week we'll pick up with
more data sonification using astronomy getting with some more realistic data i'm really excited
to see you there i'm excited to do more sonification with you again we are very grateful to pandas and
num focus for generously supporting this tutorial series and i encourage you if you have questions
to reach out to me or patrick via email or to come to our office hours same zoom link as the
tutorials 6 to 8 p.m uk time on zoom and also to check out our curriculum online where all of this
code is hosted yeah thank you so much for coming i'm excited to talk more sonification with you
all next week hopefully in a live recording if the sound permits all right thanks all
i'm just gonna wait a few seconds because i'm worried the recording is gonna like cut off the
last few seconds um and i don't want it to cut off like the actual end so if this is still in
the video sorry for this like awkward few extra seconds where i'll like wave at the camera and
sort of ramble on rambling rambling rambling also crossing my fingers that the recording
worked because if that didn't work i'll be quite sad and i guess sit here for two more hours which
would make me quite sad um so fingers crossed everyone i suppose if you're seeing me still
rambling here then it's worked all right i think that's probably enough time i'm gonna go stop